um
right good afternoon we've started the
stream welcome to those who are joining
us online i'll declare this
extraordinary performance policy and
partnerships committee meeting open
uh we have councillor clark on zoom
and apologies from councillors abbott
and lush would somebody like to move
that the apologies received councillor
lewis and councillor crackit put that
all in favor
against carried there's a major light
late item that i'll move that we accept
and that's um
a report uh aligning local pandemic
response measures to the national
guidance somebody want to see
thanks leslie
put that all in favor aye against
carried
uh purpose the primary purpose of the
extraordinary meeting is the adoption of
the annual planned consultation document
remember and of course it is the
document that goes out for consultation
um
is rhiannon introducing this
it would say not
in fact it would seem that we are light
on staff well there's a few next door
yeah that's what i think okay
and that gives me the opportunity
now rhiannon i think is supposedly
joining on zones
with you okay thank you i'm with you now
thank you
oh it's just there i'm usually standing
thank you that's fine
apologies for the delay indeed exactly
what i was about to say
if he wasn't wearing a mask i'm sure i
could see the sweet on michael morris's
upper lip
oh chris
no that's lorneville
any clue michael or do we perspective um
sorry oh
okay look if we go to the the late item
if
yep that'll give us a chance to
track down welcome pony
don't answer that please
all right yes right uh this is the late
paper that you've um
got on the table and
both steve and richard
have the opportunity to present that to
us who's leading off mr giblin
uh thank you mr chair good afternoon you
worship councillors
look as we've been doing over the last
month we've been keeping this committee
abreast of the changes going on with the
cover protection framework so this paper
just continues that trend i'm going to
pass over to richard and he's just going
to talk to you briefly about what we're
proposing today
following
the government's or
anticipating the government's changes to
the protection framework tomorrow and
seeking to delegate the decision-making
to the chief executive so pastor richard
to talk through the report
thank you um
i'd invite you to think of this report
just as a bit of good housekeeping in
preparation for tomorrow's report
we would of course always have a
preference to make it um
reach the publication deadlines and have
it debated but this isn't one of those
reports this is not saying we will make
a decision but simply saying that we may
need to delegate to an order to not be
out of step with the government
arrangements
so last december we came together we
debated we heard community views and we
listened to the views around the table
and we want to assure you that we will
continue to keep those
considerations front of mind if anything
does need to be changed but what we want
to avoid is when tomorrow's
announcements comes out from the
government if there is anything that
requires a local and immediate response
we know that our community won't
necessarily see the difference between
an announcement made from government and
what happens locally
so we want to be able to answer the
questions we want to be able to respond
to how we will react to those decisions
tomorrow we don't have a crystal ball
gosh it would be nice to go through this
endemic with a bit of foresight we know
this fatigue from change both around the
table here and our community so when we
a decision is made we want to be
consistent and quick and swift in
following whatever decisions or guidance
is given
the paper in front of you has two key
points to it it talks about the local
response measures so those are things
that we have decided under discretionary
powers or in the interests of our
community and one of the major ones that
we've talked about um quite a bit is the
use of my vaccine passport and we
suspect there will be and
that'll be in the discussion which is um
central government uh will tell us all
about tomorrow
so just to recap when we made that
decision a lot of debate around the
table it was um widely considered the
right decision and a precautionary
decision to protect our community but at
that time the conditions were slightly
different we were trying to fend off
delta we had lower vaccination rates uh
children could not be vaccinated so a
lot of
different things plus most importantly
it wasn't in the community so we were
trying to keep the virus out of our
facilities and services
as we progress through the pandemic and
understand it more we know it's in the
uh community and therefore
trying to keep it out of our facilities
is almost impossible so the factors have
changed and we're likely to see a
response around the use of that
the passports tomorrow so we want to be
able to be prepared and the best way to
do that is in the second section paper
which is to say given the understanding
of the views around the table
we propose to delegate that response
local response decision making to the
ceo
based on risk assessment and the
national guidelines
what we're not asking you here today is
for a decision around what that decision
might be and we're not preempting and
we're not saying that
the chief executive will make that
decision necessarily tomorrow but we
want to be able to respond to it
appropriately
once all those factors as risk
and guidance have been understood
so happy to take questions so
bearing in mind
as you say richard that the decision
that council made was a little above
what the national requirement was
it's our ability to and i hate this term
pivot
um but it's it's appropriate swiftly
with
potentially one of a variety of
directions that we can go if it is about
um that the government announces that
the vaccination passports are no longer
required
one of the concerns is that it's at
least another couple of weeks until this
committee
meets again and
rather than call an extraordinary
meeting to
re-litigate the issue
um
uh it would potentially delegate that
responsibility to the chief executive
alternatively it could be that a date
announced
is
in three weeks time
in which case the decision of the chief
executive could be we have this
opportunity at the next pppm meeting on
such and such a date to review that
decision is is that my read of the
absolutely correct yeah and i
there was an interesting article written
last night uh that was in on stuff
that mentioned the reason why there's
been a delay from monday's announcement
through to tomorrow when it sorry that
monday's decision through to the
announcement tomorrow it's based on the
fact this isn't a highly responsive
time in the pandemic it's not like when
we had to go up a level or introduce a
further restriction and we were given 48
hours we're expecting to see a few
triggers that are in the future tomorrow
there might be some immediate stuff but
there might be things that says
this region or this dhb is at this peak
so therefore they can have this criteria
and when that happens down here then we
might see the same thing so there might
be a bit of leeway
but we just don't want to be caught on
the back foot
if and this is we're not second guessing
anything but hypothetically if it was
something around when we open the
borders to australians who have
vaccination passes that don't work on
our system there might be a bit of
conflict
there so it's trying to be able to
respond to those kind of issues as they
arise sensibly
and
meeting the expectations of the
community because you know as soon as
that announcement is made
we will have to respond and say what our
position is
we're also aware that we've got a lot of
frontline staff who have been dealing
with the
both sides of the conversation as people
come into the
facilities and what we don't want is for
them to have no script and no guidance
about what the council position is
especially when people are saying but
governments just said this why haven't
you sort of thing we don't want to put
our staff in that position if we can
have that
delegated decision we may if necessarily
be able to give guidance in an immediate
effect or as you say wait to the next
meeting whatever we do
we signaled we would come back to you
for further debate
and discussion in that december meeting
so we will come back with you and there
will be an opportunity to look at how
we've responded to the plan to the
mandates the pandemic what worked what
we've learned for the future and also
any key
discussions and debates that we need to
have about returning to fully uh to a
fully engaged community service so
there will be opportunity for that thank
you okay councillors
i intend to handle it in this way if you
have any questions
i'll
allow those to be asked now but we'll
get into the debate once we actually
have a motion on the table so if we can
just deal with questions first then
we'll get a motion and then we'll have a
discussion counselor potentially do you
have a question yes it is a question you
mentioned the word
risk assessment now council did not was
not forced by government to introduce
the passport system
for in fact in fact the ce
under who's in control of health and
safety
um did not implement it either
um
yet you were saying to
uh to remove the passport system you
would do a risk assessment now i find
that quite interesting because when i
look back at the debate on december 7th
council
voted a majority voted
to implement the passport system with no
risk assessment
so i'm a bit baffled that
you do you get into something without a
risk assessment and then you use a risk
assessment to get out it's like making a
stupid decision and then making a wise
one
you know it doesn't sort of follow logic
to me but so what's your question why
why the risk assessment certainly and we
didn't need one we didn't do one the
first place through you mr if we cast
our minds back the uh we did there was
an operational decision made
uh which was to as i understand it not
to use passports in the first instance
and there was feedback from the elected
members to say hey we want to just test
this with community appetite etc prior
to that meeting we had actually gone
through a risk assessment we do this
with all of our decisions
we did a risk profile of our staff and
the sort of environments that they work
in we sort of scored that
and we took that in that original
decision for what we made
in terms of the report that was
presented to you the risk assessment was
much more anecdotal but the science had
been done prior to that and we'd also
followed the risk assessments of
national um of the national guidelines
um
so do you believe it was done in
accordance with the local government
attack in the asset in the way that
elector members have to make decisions
um i'll defer that to probably chief
executive can answer that but from my
perspective there was good robust debate
and there was a lot of information i
don't believe we got to the end of the
meeting with anything unsaid or any
questions unanswered but i'd defer to
miss hadley
i'm sorry
councillor pottinger could you repeat
the question the question was that
it was
under consideration and i don't believe
that our council
and its obligation to the local
government act and decision making
process
actually followed that in considering
the risk assessment at all
under the requirements of the act
uh councillor pottinger i have no doubt
that that report over which almost every
member of elt sweated over a weekend in
order to put it before you
and considered the options analysis with
the exception of some days being
vax passports and some days not as mr
tribe subsequently suggested
the risk i think there are two things
that you're
interchanging here and one is the risk
around health and safety for which we
did a risk assessment on all staff
all positions i should say rather than
start as opposed to the risk which you
are talking about there which may be a
right a wider risk such as reputational
risk or risk to financial budgets
which is a different matter
which is covered by the act
which is indeed covered by the act in
which i'm satisfied that the report you
received on the 7th december would have
met all of the standards of the act
council made a policy decision
that
had viewed that information but chose to
go in a different direction correct okay
any other questions
if not uh i'm looking for a motion on
the table councillor sopa i'll move both
recommendations one and two mr chair
okay seconded councillor emmonson
now it's open for discussion
councillor scalp
thank you through you chia um richard
just should the government make an
immediate decision on the passes
tomorrow in a very
short time frame what would be
um
great for other venues within the city
is if we could have a collective
response in the sense of time frames as
well so that we're not mixing and
matching
so i guess the time lag may be an issue
in the sense of how we react
but it'd be great i'll use our venue as
an example if we could be in line
um time frame wise and whatever so
i think the time frames are going to be
set nationally
no no the time frame that we make
we make it communication is the key it's
our communication is the key
so we're going to deal with that outside
of the meeting
no no because
yes no
sorry
i understand what you're saying and i
don't disagree that we can't achieve it
but it's not actually part of what we're
discussing which is around the decision
to be able to pivot
if it's helpful we've heard that and we
will certainly make sure that we get the
communication out across your peers
thank you
counselors any other comments
counselor sofa as as the mover i just
want to say it seems to me that we are
being invited to make a
very pragmatic and sensible decision
here
we don't know what the announcement on
wednesday may mean
but we certainly as a council
have the obligation to be prepared for
it and this is a very pragmatic way of
of being prepared
and we certainly know that we have
meetings coming up where report backs
will take place so i am quite
comfortable in moving this
this very sensible recommendation thank
you mr chair councillor cracker
uh thank you mr chair i'm just speaking
in support of the motion as well um i
think it's like
how you very rightly said that it's just
so that we don't get out of step with
the rest of the country and others who
may choose to open venues across the
community community when they have the
ability to do so so we don't want to be
on the back foot waiting for another
meeting or for us to all have to get
together collectively it's a step of
pro-activity and it's so we can answer
to the community in an immediate fashion
anyone else
counselor clark my apologies
problems uh listen to the debate uh
around this issue and just want to
reinforce what claire said
um
and what were councillor
pottinger was alluding to
um
we can't lose sight of the fact that we
have some obligations under health and
safety and employment act and that's
separate from the local government act
and so
while we have some obligation to do risk
assessment
um
either way
we still have to consider
what the risks will be for our staff and
employer as opposed to
risk to the general public using our
venue so just wanted to reinforce what
claire will say early on
relax
anybody speaking against the motion
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
aye against
carried thank you for that
uh we return to
the um
annual plan consultation document random
good afternoon
um
so yes so they'll first just draw all
councillors to attention to the fact
that you've received an updated version
of the consultation document that's
being discussed in this report so that's
on tab five of board books that's the
latest version
new so that is the version to be adopted
for consultation so just to alert you to
what the changes are they are just small
changes like some of the teleo's
headings were not yet complete
at the time of the agenda production
days have been corrected
a few small um typing areas have been
corrected
um a section explaining the um
difference in rates has just been the
wording has been clarified following the
southern times article where the meaning
was not quite picked up correctly
and um some clarification on the options
title has been made so they are all
quite small changes but just to alert
you to that
um so
rhiannon i'm sorry can i just say
to all of the committee i am aware there
was an administrative
um
snafu
uh on in loading the document onto board
books
given some updates that were made and
for the purposes of true administrative
belt and braces
i think it would be wise i'm sorry mr
chair i didn't think about this till
this very point but i think it would be
wise to receive this as a major late
item
noting that some attachments were
dropped in an update i can see
councillor sopa was also aware of this
some attachments were dropped they were
reinstated over the weekend and my
thanks to the staff to the elected
members who pointed it out and to the
staff who came in and made that happen
but for that reason for those of us who
take these matters seriously be wise to
receive it i'm happy to move that we
receive it as a major late item second
council amundsen discussion
what is the vote all in favor
against
carried apologies for the interruption
really sorry can i
can i just suggest that in um the
recommendation number three the number
has changed
to a three eight fifty two four seven
yes
thanks thank you councillor sopher
um
so
in summarizing the report i'll um draw
you your attention to
a few key points about the process and
then
patricia is just going to cover off the
key points from the financial
budgeting point of view
um so this consultation document
outlines the primary issue for
consultation in this annual plan which
is the options for te anua
the museum
those options were confirmed at the
infrastructural meeting on the 15th of
march
there are a number of other matters for
consultation them that are not
that are supplementary to the annual
plan
um the next of those is the change of
reserve status for tisbury reserve and
again the options and for that matter
were
discussed and confirmed on the 15th of
march
and finally the fees and charges will be
consulted at the same time as the annual
plan um and that will be dealt with in
the paper subsequent to this
so um the annual plan outlines the
changes
from the year two of the long-term plan
it summarizes those changes from a
financial and operational point of view
and it provides the community an
opportunity to provide feedback to you
councillors prior to the final annual
plan being adopted before the end of
june and then the rates struck
this report covers off the engagement
process
for the consultation there will be a
range of
resources available
and activities
online and offline so happy to
take any questions but in the meantime
i'll pass over to patricia just to
summarize the key financial course
thanks rhiannon so in relation to the
financials um as randon said we did
start with year two of the ltp um
as the base however um we've had to
change a number of assumptions to
reflect the changing environment which
we were all facing
at the moment
who would have thought in june last year
we would have been had a cpi of 5.9
percent
we were projecting something closer to
two or three
um so we have reflected some changes of
assumptions
in this plan
we have maintained our inflation
assumption at 2.9 because we haven't
seen the increase in the local
government cost index
as that was produced before the major
inflationary changes in the last quarter
this also
different from the ltp reflects the
decisions which you as a council have
made in relation to city streets stage
two and bringing that capital progress
project into next year
and with your preferred option of the
museum
so the budgets attached and the cons to
the supporting information to the
consultation document reflect
option two
so the larger of the museum options
includes your city streets decisions
it also reflects some changes that
central government have placed on
council including the increase in
minimum wage
and we have now reflected and
provided additional budget to ensure
that our icc fair wage keeps its um
different differential to the new
minimum wage it will come in on the
first of april
and we've also reflected that our work
programs required some focus in relation
to
building conditions
assessments and asbestos
assessments so additional funding was
put in for those and on the repairs and
maintenance of our property portfolio
and that resulted
predominantly with
the change in rates from a four percent
which was the forecast rates increase
for 22 23 in the long term plan
to 7.78
that and for the average
um at present the average residential
rate payers rates this year at 2 475
that will increase to 2668
so an increase of 193 dollars
per year
in relation to the net debt position
the increase in the capital program
does increase the net debt position
and we will see a peak net debt position
in 2627 now of 192 million
um however the 150 revenue benchmark
which you've set and the financial
policy is met
and this is a result of the increased
revenue
from rates
achieving that
however there are two benchmarks that
will not and those are the ones around
rates affordability where the level will
set at 7.5 percent rates increase
as the draft goes out those will not be
achieved
so um is there any questions either on
the financials
um
we are getting tight for time but i
don't want to shortcut counsellor's
ability to have a discussion
bearing in mind this is just the
consultation document that's going out
um
and we've got a council meeting that's
due to start
in about two minutes
so i'm going to adjourn this meeting
here and i'll reconvene it at the end of
council because i don't want to cut this
short i mean we need to value what it is
we put out in that consultation document
so i'll adjourn this meeting sorry
patricia uh and apologies rhiannon but
we'll come back to it uh once council's
completed
oh
[Music]
sticking out the bottom i need a plugin
[Music]
thank you
are you looking for an increase in
funding
[Laughter]
i thought you were putting on twice
thank you
delete
let me stop standing
good afternoon fellow councillors
members of staff
public and the media
open with the council prayer
almighty god grant to us all needed
guidance wisdom
and judgment
as we face the tasks before us
and enable us now
and always worthily to discharge
the sacred trust placed by the people
in our hands
amen
apologies our counselor lush
any declarations of interest
no
public forum any submissions
again
now the major late items
uh 4.1 minutes of the
infrastructural services committee
held on the 1st of march 2022
the reason
that the item is not on the agenda
is that the report was not ready in time
for the egypt when the agenda was
published
the reason why the discussion of the
item cannot be delayed
as matters can progress in an entire in
an entirely
timely manner
to be
moved
that the minutes of the extraordinary
meeting of the performance policy
partnerships committee held on the 22nd
february you wish
i think you've moved on from the mata
the major late item you'll need a motion
that those minutes be accepted as a
major late item
all
right
and i think councillor amundsen is
prepared to move and councillor sopra is
prepared to second
thank you it's been moved and seconded
put it to the voucher all in favor say i
i against carried
now we click on on item
thank you your worship odd move that the
minutes of the extraordinary meeting of
performance policy and partnerships from
february 22nd be received and adopted
thank you seconder for that
second that
moved and seconded
question questions put it to the vote
all in favor say aye
aye against carrick
move on to item six
that the minutes of the meeting of the
council held
on the 22nd of february 2022
be confirmed
moved and seconded
discussion questions
put it to the bathroom in favor say aye
aye against carried
to be moved to the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of the performance
policy partnerships committee held on
the 1st of march 2022
be received happy to move that your
worship
thank you
second that your worship
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the bathroom in favor say aye
aye against carried
the minutes of the performance policy
partnerships committee
meeting held on the 8th of march 22nd
22
be received yes your worship we
certainly have some extraordinary
meetings with performance policy and
partnership and with another one to
continue after this but in this instance
i'm happy to move that we received the
minutes from march 1st
oh sorry um
march 8th
and your worship is councillor ludlow
moving the recommendation also
yes
the amendment to the well-being front i
apologize
and there's a second uh yes oh sorry
cancer edmondson
discussion questions put it to the vote
all in favor say aye aye
against carried
the minutes of the extraordinary meeting
of the infrastructural services
committee held
on the 15th of march 2022
i'll move that your worship and the
recommendations within it within it and
including
the amendments
without sorry the alterations
for that
second that your worship
thank you councillor
put it to the vote hold on favor say i
that the minutes of the infrastructural
services committee held on the 1st of
march 2022 we received
yes i'll move that that be received as
well as the
recommend um
there were
no emotion from
was defeated
the recommendation in relation to the
disposal of land for pump station yeah
thank you
i'll move that
i'll second that you worship
thank you
moved and seconded
every
um
resolution would be that
the disposal of land for the pump
station purposes
and that the application be made to the
minister of conservation
requesting the portion of land required
to be transferred
to southland regional council
environment southland
pursuant to section 52
of the public works act 1981
being moved as part of the previous
resolution
agent business any agent business
i'm
not sure that you've put that motion
here
the motion to receive the minutes
and the recommendation has been moved
and seconded but it hasn't yet been put
your worship
okay
i'll put that to the boat
all in favor say all right
against carried
now we move on to urgent business
thank you well thanks to
uh there is public excluded jewish
yes thanks to all the staff who are here
i don't think there's anyone in the
media
um
and i'll declare the
public excluded session
and thank you for your presence here
today
and your worship oh
i'll um move that we go into public
excluded with the exception of mr grant
secondly
for the reasons as stated in the agenda
still live stream
i wonder your worship with just
receiving minutes we could actually just
carry on
move to receive them an open meeting
[Music]
okay well if there's no objections for
just
carrying on
um your worship
um i would be happy to move
uh
all five sets of public excluded minutes
second that and one recommendation to
council
did i see
three yes
including
that particular recommendation
that i'm looking at
right there
okay
so
on my
friendship
we go to
[Music]
item one be moved
you worship i'm sorry councillor ludlow
i wonder if we might proceed to public
excluded
and it's fine i was just trying to save
us having to stop we have a motion
on the floor
that needs to be dealt with and the
motion was councillor sopa move that we
go into public excluded and it was
seconded by
a councillor
so the appropriate thing to do would be
to put that motion now your worship
thank you yes i'll put the motion in all
in favor say aye aye
against carriage
so the clark has a question
just before we could we stay in
uh i'm not sure do you need to separate
andrew between council and note
wonderful
so councillor ludlow is probably going
to return to the top seat and invite you
to change places
and we'll go back to the adoption of the
consultation document discussion
if patricia is
in the house
thanks for your forbearance counselors
staff
zoomers
uh i'll reconvene the extraordinary
performance policy and partnerships
committee meeting in our last episode
we've just gone through some of the
financial implications involved uh for
widers that we're going uh back out to
consultation and what's contained in the
consultation document
and patricia had run through some of
those
reasons we now are at the stage
of seeing if you have any questions
first of all before we
move into
uh
debating a couple of issues bearing in
mind that we're not
debating the issues these are questions
absolutely counselor arnold please i
just got a little bit of a question
when we go to consultation with this
document because this is a consultation
document if the majority of the feedback
come back and say hey hey look we're
absolutely against that
do we have a plan to trim off 1.9 of
expenditure or
defer something is is there like a plan
b
because that could happen couldn't it
because it's consultation we're going
out for
so is there a
so counselor i'm going to stick to the
rules around process i know call me a
bureaucrat
um but let's be a good one
so um the real process is that you're
going out to hear people's views
and i encourage you all to have an open
mind and to hear from all sectors of the
community as to what they like and what
they might not like
we will come back with a report at the
end of consultation
and tell you submitters views
you will determine
whether you will
take those views into account or whether
you have more information than they do
or can see other reasons
if you wish to trim it can i
round it up to two percent and make it
easy if you reached it from one percent
two percent five percent
then it's absolutely within your purview
to do so
however you would need to take into
account what were you going to change in
the levels of service
and whether that in itself needed
consultation
but my question to you
executive is um you would have to
show us where we could possibly do that
if that was the requirement
uh mr chair
i'm very happy to meet this challenge uh
this is a partnership
and i would be very happy for the team
in in me to give you some suggestions
however i will say publicly
that those suggestions which have been
made is that have driven the prices or
the rates increase up
some are as a result of previous council
decisions
where you were advised of what those
increases would be and some are as a
result of officers saying to you we need
to do a better job
i'm thinking specifically around the
property area
where
there's earthquake assessments to be
done condition assessments things that
we need to do as part of asset
management in preparation for the next
long-term plan they're boring
uh the community doesn't see much for it
but equally they are where the audit
office will tell you that you the
elected members have not done your job
correctly if you don't have that
information to make decisions
where you say to me look the community
just can't bear this cost we need to
trim our sales
how can we do that
then i would say to you
there are some choices you will need to
make some
decisions and that's where it can be
very difficult for elected members
because quite frankly it can be where
you feel the heat
i
it is what you're here for and i could
suggest to you that we could sell some
pieces of land that would mean that we'd
get more rates in or reduce our
operating costs i could suggest to you
that we would have less
attractive gardens in our roundabouts or
the street edges i could suggest to you
that we would reduce the hours of
operation at some of our facilities such
as the library or the pools
some of those would mean that we would
then need to go back and ask the
community which do you want most higher
rates or lesser hours so it becomes a
really complicated
roundabout and that's where i say it's
it's not always easy
the ce raises a point a good point that
um
really the only options
if in this annual plan if we want to
chop something we can chop something
that is new to the long-term plan is
that right clear
so rather than if we go and try and chop
a level of service we would have to
reconsult
um mr chia there are levels of service
and levels of service what i mean by
that is that the habits through
roundabouts a great example where we've
actually done a different presentation
that will have an ongoing reduction in
operating costs but for us to do all of
the roundabouts in the city at one hit
would be
a big cost dinner and not in the program
that's a level of service that we
wouldn't need to consult on but changing
the operating hours that's the type of
thing
where it had a significant impact the
word significant always goes hand in
hand with the levels of service that
would have an impact that we'd need to
go back another example i would give you
is that the customer service center now
opens at 8 30 instead of 8 o'clock we
didn't consult on that
but if you were to change its levels of
service from being open five days a week
to four
then i think that would have a
significant
factor put in front of it that would
mean that you'd need to consult no
thanks that's answered that question
thanks councillor clark
sure just a couple of just a reflection
ready for me and and a couple of
questions
for uh rhiannon a bit further on in the
documents we're putting out
um so from my my perspective um the
document and i'm not trying to relocate
this i know i know it goes out to the
committee and we need to get it out
there but from my perspective
we haven't disclosed enough information
on this document to show the public
why we are going to the additional 3.78
on top of the ltp
without looking at other options and
council arnold's quite right to raise
those there are a range of them but
they're not all done personal costs as
the chiefs are going to suggest there
are a whole lot raft of areas that we
could instead of cutting costs actually
increase our revenue
or our funding weights so we don't
necessarily need to go out and say well
um
we're going to cut this service we're
going to cut that service because
we don't approve 7.78
because the other side of the equation
is a balanced budget is a match of
income or revenue versus the productive
expenditure so you don't have to cut the
expenditure you can actually increase
the ribbon but i'm not here to debate
that today now there's another place for
me to do that
so i just wanted to reflect on that i
think there's a range of other options
that we may or may not have considered i
know i've spoken about in the past but
the document doesn't show our ratepayers
that we have done some due diligence on
those options and i think they have a
right to know that before we start
talking about uh an increase higher than
the long term plan
the last issue for me is just purely on
tab five board books on page 136
and there's a comment there a sort of
frequently asked questions provision and
what it does is it says that we with the
new designs going forward for the new
museum are not committed to a permanent
shape and i wonder why that is because
we had significant feedback from our
community about a year ago that one of
the things they wanted to retain was not
necessarily the pyramid roof but the
pyramid shape
and if we're going to go out and consult
with people about this then i just don't
understand why we drop that in the
design factors
rihanna
um i will pass on the specific on that
question to steve
giblin if he is in prison
yeah thank you through you mr chair um
counselor
um
where we're at in the design process
with uh tayanoa is
spatial considerations to establish the
best option and the primary focus of the
work as you know
has been around establishing the vision
and critical success factors
it hasn't been towards designing a
facility
or telling the design team we want it to
look this way we just had to focus on
version critical success factors in the
location which is the decision from the
long term plan that's about as far as
we've gone
but we can
certainly through this process all three
options are being discussed and we're
looking forward to hearing back from the
community what they're looking for
councillor pottinger
yeah thank you chair look i would
dispute the fact that the public do want
that shape there was comment made
but there was no way no way in the world
an overwhelming desire to keep it
and there was
i cannot remember at any stage any any
significant weight of people
who wish to keep the pyramid shape
going forward
right counselors
sorry what we're doing ms
who are you pointing at ella obviously
robbie's got his hand up oh sorry as
your hand up again
my apologies this is the point of
clarity i i won't get into it today but
i will find the feedback from the
community that they recommend the
pyramid just for council ponder's
benefit might be yours
thanks
right
we're after a motion
which brings us back
to the recommendations there are uh four
of them with that uh correction
uh on number three to eight three eight
fifty two four seven
so full recommendation somebody prepared
to move councillor scout and council
association
it's open for discussion
there is none i put the motion all in
favor
against
carried and thank you for doing so
unanimously we look forward to um people
taking the opportunity
to participate in providing us with some
with some feedback i mean obviously
sometimes the idea between about a
long-term plan is you shouldn't have to
go out and do an annual plan but when
you uh need to move as much as we have
obviously there's a need for
consultation so we look forward to
hearing what people have to say and
thanks to those who've responded
so far to emily for
the various consultation events
there being no further items of
general business i'll move that the
meeting is closed now i'll close the
meeting in the stream thank those who've
joined us on stream
the adoption of the fees and charges
schedule oh goodness
thank you
massive
thank you
actually
from brianna
attention first oh i was wet i did start
raising my hands so thanks to those that
spotted you small interpretive dance
next time might be useful
yes so the phasing charges are provided
here again for adoption prior to
consultation um
i'll just
touch on some key points so as always
the cover report
provides an overview for where the
officers are making recommendations
for changes to the fees and charges
a number of factors have been considered
in putting these recommendations
together
those include of course making sure that
we are covering costs and providing
services and making sure that we are not
requiring rates income for those
services where the most suitable
mechanism to cover costs is through
facing charges
officers have considered
different approaches
to providing some services and that is
explained in the cover report
i'll draw your attention to the fact
that many of the fees and charges
particularly in the regulatory area are
set by different pieces of legislation
there
have been no increases in these fees and
charges at this time and therefore we
have written to local government new
zealand to draw attention to the fact
that
costs are going up
and that it would be useful for central
government to consider
these
matters
to ensure that local government has the
tools needed to cover
costs um
so all of the
different changes in the fees and
charges are laid out in the table within
the report and a document
based on this will also be provided to
the public at the time of consultation
to aid them
in
providing feedback on the fees and
charges
happy to take any questions thank you
any questions counselors
there are another three recommendations
is the remover
councillor scout celts and a partner
mrs coote
right my supporter oh okay
that case i'll put it to the vote all in
favor aye aye against
carried
this time this time sure
no
i do know there is a briefing afterwards
um
but that's not actually forming part of
this meeting so this time i will uh
thank the zoomers for their appearance
and to clear the meeting closed